bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette fois en question sur un tract
aux sciences fois en question pour
lequel j'ai loupé le plaisir
d'accueillir christophe hendrix
christophe bonjour donc christophe tu es
toujours en argentine
al houni d'adp et écoutons la lidho lio
de san miguel de tucuman donc au muséum
de tucuman si si j'ai bien compris où tu
es pas les retables et donc on t'a déjà
invité plein de fois tu es notre
paléontologues touche à tout la dernière
fois on a parlé de la queue de
spinosaures et cette fois on va parler
de la queue de jura venator mais aussi
et surtout du cloaque de psittacosaurus
voilà on a des sujets variés avec
christophe il est toujours légèrement
tendancieux on a tendance à se payer sur
la que je ne sais pourquoi mais quoi
donc
déjà on va peut-être commencer par
parler du cloaque de psittacosaurus
parce que c'est quelque chose qu'on nous
a demandé donc vous voyez quand vous
nous faites des demandes on vous écoute
et on vous apporte les paléontologues
qui participent aux articles puisqu'il y
a deux articles et il y en a un au moins
des deux auquel tu as participé donc
alors dans la christophe la première
question qu'est-ce qui nous apprend ce
cloaque lexique alors déjà comment il
est préservé
et qu'est ce qui nous attend ce oui
alors je vais commencer par la
publication dewinter idole puisque tu
l'as dis toi même il ya deux
publications on va expliquer pourquoi il
y en a deux d'ailleurs parce que ce sont
deux publications de d'equipe
différentes donc il ya une histoire
derrière je ne sais pas s'il est
intéressant mais en tout cas oui il ya
pas mal de choses à dire là dessus
donc je vais commencer évidemment par
celle dewinter qui a été publiée qui
était dans peer review et qui a été
révisé par par des scientifiques qui a
été publiée en tant que correspondante
est un type de page en fait c'est
relativement court dans la revue quand
même prestigieux de current biology un
qui a un impact factor facteurs
impactent assez élevé et donc voilà ce
sont des auteurs qui décrivent pour la
première fois plus ou moins en détail le
cloaque préserver de psittacosaurus
cloaque
il n'est connu que chez ce spécimen pour
tous les dinosaures non aviens donc
c'est pour ça que c'est très intéressant
c'est le premier cloaque est l'unique
dont on a connaissance par conséquent il
nous offre beaucoup d'informations quand
tu es bien l'anatomie de ce cloaque
savoir un peu quel était le la
morphologie de cet organe compilateur ex
crétois donc on parle en fait du
spécimen de psychiatres sitac aux orris
de francfort donc c'est un spécimen avec
une histoire un peu controversé puisque
c'est un spécimen qui a été acheté sur
le marché il ya plusieurs dizaines
d'années de cela par un collecteur et ce
qui l'était pas italien je ne m'en
rappelle pas mais bref qu'il a légué à
ce un muséum de francfort donc allemand
c'est un spécimen de chine dont
malheureusement nous n'avons pas
d'informations très précises ne savons
pas exactement d'où il provient on sait
plus ou moins en quelle province de
chine
mais on peut juste dire qu'il vient du
crétacé inférieur puisque tous les psys
tac aux orres viennent de cette partie
de l'échelle des temps géologiques
c'est un spécimen qui est vachement
connu puisque c'est celui qui a démontré
que si ta cause russe avait des genres
de de filaments sur la queue c'est
absolument donc c'est sa gelée j'allais
en parler tout de suite c'est un
spécimen tout à fait exceptionnelle pour
plusieurs choses mais surtout pour son
tégument donc c'est un spécimen qui
préserve une grande partie de la peau
écailleuse donc c'est le spécimen le
mieux préservé au niveau de cette peau
écailleuse alors ça qu'on parte pas
évidemment avec les spécimens de
théropodes avec plein de plus mais tout
ça mais là on parle de peau écailleuse
donc c'est le dinh
heures on a bien le mieux préservé au
niveau de la peau écailleuse et puis le
préserver également c'est filaments
assez épais au niveau de la queue ce qui
a démontré donc certains horny titien
comme celui-là est ainsi que diane
langue qui est un hétéro de vos rides et
donc on va dire un ornithischiens
relativement basale préserver également
des filaments alors il ya toujours un
débat s'est pas exactement si ce sont
des filaments qui son homologue à ceux
qui sont portés par les les théropodes
donc là on a vraiment des stades de
complexité différentes qui nous mène
jusqu'à une la plume des oiseaux mais en
tout cas donc c'est un spécimen qui
préserve ses filaments tégument terre au
niveau de la queue et est donc également
un cloaque le seul et unique l'un à
cloaque préservée chez un dinosaures non
aviens donc un spécimen excessivement
important est également des pigments
tégument terre qui nous démontre dans
une publication par winter ce même
moteur qui travaillent sur le cloaque
que c'est un dinosaure qui manifestement
utiliser une sorte de mimétisme
on pense que le le le ventre le poitrail
était plus plus clair que le reste du
corps
donc on a des pigments et c'est
également le cas vrai dire avec le club
donc je vais enlever le décrire
succinctement vinther en fait constate
que c'est un un cloaque et préserver
postérieurement à une callosités donc
une protubérance qui est formé par
l'ischion un lit science et cet os du
bassin qui pointe les ornithischiens
vers l'arrière donc c'est une ouverture
d'après vinther qui est délimitée à
l'avant par deux l'air importante
protubérantes latéral qui convergent
antérieurement et et qui forment une
sorte de v d'air devant lequel derrière
pendant derrière lequel devait se situer
l'ouverture du cloaque est donc derrière
l'ouverture du cloaque il y aurait
également un lob dorsale avec plusieurs
plusieurs plie comme sa célèbre
latérales sont fortement pigmentées on
le voit très bien elles sont très foncée
et elles sont couvertes de petites
écailles de 3 à 6 mm qui sont imbriquées
le lob d'ordre ce talent derrière
l'ouverture du cloaque à des écailles
différentes de différentes densités avec
et puis l'on dit nino et alors ce qu'il
propose et c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant et qu'elle a été publiée
dans une revue quand même important
c'est que il propose en fait que c'est
lèvres latéral foncé et bien avait une
sorte de rôle de signalements sociale
une fonction de signalements visuel qui
permettait donc à aux mâles ou femelles
lancé rien de localiser le cloaque et
alors ils pensent également que se clôt
rec même s'ils n'ont pas des preuves
avait peut-être également un rôle
olfactif all your head et des glandes de
secret sion comme on en retrouve chez
les crocodiliens et filez chez des
oiseaux et donc il propose non seulement
à une fonction de signalements visuel
mais elle est également une fonction
l'oeuf active pour ce cloaque et occuper
cette fonction de signalements visuelle
elle est déjà la fonction phéromones à
le dire ouais pour les faits romagne ya
aucune ya aucune preuve de ça tu l'as
bien dit quand le signalement visuelle
par contre ça intéressant c'est quand
même une interprétation qui se base sur
la présence donc de pigments sur sept ce
cloaque
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on a des bonnes
raisons de penser que la pigmentation
qu'on voit sur le cloaque et de la vraie
pigmentation naturel je pense je pense
vraiment pour la simple et bonne raison
qu'il y a eu une publication
autre publication a été publiée quelques
années auparavant sur la coloration de
ce petit à cause or plusieurs spécimens
donc oui manifestement je me rappelle
quand même qu'il dise dans cet article
qui n'ont pas retrouvé de melano zone
c'est à dire ces organites qui qui donne
l'information sur la couleur par exemple
chez les plumes on en retrouve très
souvent chez les plumes qui nous
permettent de savoir si les plumes sont
plutôt clairs ou foncés
on ne retrouve par exemple chez les
consommateurs préférant qui ornis et
tout ça ici je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
retrouvé thème de la nauze hommes mais
en tout cas ils pensent vraiment que
l'animal montrent des des zones foncées
claire qui qui qui ne doivent pas être
tard ponot mais qui doit vraiment être
dû à la pigmentation réel de la peau de
cet animal ce qui est logique à on voit
vraiment des zones plutôt clair au
niveau du ventre c'est le cas par
exemple de la queue et pour le cloarec
et foncez donc du couac et on peut on
peut quand même être relativement
confident confiant pendant confiant sur
la la véracité de cette de ces
pigmentation chez un psy tac aux orres
donc
donc voilà par contre en revanche qu'ils
ne sont pas capables de dire c'est que
ils ne savent pas si le cloaque cette
ouverture locale est allongé
longitudinal et en forme de fentes comme
chez les crocodiles bien ou plutôt comme
suit les oiseaux c'est à dire une heure
un cloaque arrondi rond sur sub
circulaire
donc voilà
lille reste en suspens encore là ils
sont ils sont ils constituent donc le
cloaque avec ses deux lèvres de laives
qui ne se retrouve pas chez d autres
animaux ont par exemple fait les
crocodiliens ou bien de lèvres mais qui
comment je vais décrire ça qui sont
faites latéral par rapport à l'ouverture
longitudinale duclos a qui forment une
sorte de deux mille disques de part et
d'autre donc gauche et droite
ici en revanche on a des lobes dans ce
sont pas des loges ce sont des lèvres
latéral qui converse qui forment une
invite comme ça où se situe le cloaque
entre ces de l'est ça c'est ce serait
tout à fait propre à ce dinosaure et
peut être à d'autres dinosaures
encore une fois on entend les oiseaux ne
servent et l'oiseau c'est un simple un
peu rond avec une sorte d'anneau
arrondies qui donc les différentes de
cette fente allongé qui se retrouvent
donc chez les crocodiliens et peut-être
type si tu accordes d'accord et il
arrive à déterminer le sexe le
psittacosaurus du coup n'ont en effet
alors ils en parlent ils en parlent très
brièvement si je ne me trompe
en tout cas ils ne peuvent pas se
prononcer quant au sexe de l'animal pour
la simple et bonne raison que les
organes copulatoire donc des
crocodiliens des oiseaux et donc de
psittacosaurus à certains points
importants sont internes et là
uniquement le cloaque externe est
préservée donc on a aucune
aucun organe copilote war qui est
préservée chez ce spécimen donc on peut
pas savoir s'il s'agit là d'un mal qui
aurait un pénis on pense vraiment que
les dinosaures avait un pénis rétracte
toit rétractable enfants comme chez les
cocos d'illiez et les oiseaux mais ce
pénis n'est pas préservée donc on ne
sait pas s'il s'agit d'un mâle et d'une
femelle
il ya certains oiseaux qui ont un pénis
rétractable notamment les plus basses
eaux comme les anatidés donc les canards
et lra tite
oui les autres c'est pas tous les
oiseaux qui ont qui ont un pénis mais
comme les plus bas au long s'il ya de
bonnes raisons de croire que les
dinosaures n'avait quoi payer 11 ans
lama vient étant donné que les
crocodiliens donc qui sont les plus
proches parents des dinosaures qui ne
sont pas des dinosaures ont un pénis
rétractable et que les d'oise ou qui
sont des dinosaures sont des théropodes
donc en tout cas les plus basses eaux
ont un pénis et bien on imagine tout
simplement d'un point de vue de la
phylogénie de la classification des
archosaures que les dinosaures de l'été
se déposséder également infinie ok donc
on peut pas déterminer le sexe parce que
le pénis est cachée à l'intérieur donc
les mâles et les femelles se ressemblent
du coup est ce qu'on peut en déduire
quoi que ce soit par rapport à la
reproduction des de la façon dont ils se
reproduisent est ce ça c'est une
question qui revient souvent est ce
qu'ils se monter dessus les dinosaures
estiment que d'avoir un ministre et
tracteurs donc lors de la population ce
pénis de sortir du cloaque et devait
s'insérer dans le dans clock des
femelles donc mais est-ce que ce cloaque
se clôt est lui-même ne nous informe pas
sur le si ce n'est donc le rôle de
signalements on devait on pouvait
imaginer que les mâles et les femelles
devait se renifler le derrière et se
reconnaître peut-être de loin ou où
est-ce que alors j'en sais rien je pars
dans des hypothèses mais est-ce que la
coloration du cloaque pouvait changer
l'ordre lorsque l'économie était en or
ou des choses comme ça en rut
je n'en sais strictement rien mais en
tout cas sur le le mode de copulation
des dinosaures la morphologie du cloaque
ne le dit pas grand chose en fait ce
qu'on sait maintenant mais ça semble
tout à fait logique et on revient encore
une fois avec avec donc cette parenté
phylogénétique un bitume et traductions
en anglais c'est qu'on savait quand même
que le club devait se situer au niveau
de la partie antérieure de la queue très
proche d'eux
les deux listes y ont donc là voilà
c'est confirmé avec ce spécimen on sait
maintenant que le plan qui se situe
juste derrière cette callosités septième
position donc voilà le la copulation
devait se faire tout simplement avec un
animal qui devait monter la femelle et
le pénis inséré dans le code de la
famille mais ça en fermage wilko alors
s'en doutait déjà par rapport aux
normales je me demande chez les oiseaux
est ce qu'on est ce que les oiseaux
utilisent vraiment effet romane donc
l'utilisation des phéromones chez les
oiseaux chez les arcs aux enfants en
général ça risque d'être compliqué parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de nom pas d'organe
voméronasal donc le organes vomero nasa
c'est ça normalement qui utilisent les
phéromones donc faire l'hypothèse
l'utilisation des phéromones chez les
dinosaures chez les dinosaures non plus
il n'ya pas d'organe voméronasal déjà à
cause du field génétique bracketting
mais aussi parce qu'on ya une cavité
dans l'os vos mères qui est dédié à
l'organe voméronasal et on la retrouve
pas chez les dinosaures
donc ce serait quand même ce serait
étonnant qu'ils aient une fonction
phéromones al donc c'est bizarre quand
même qu'il fasse cette hypothèse
les quotidiens ont quand même une glande
parra cloaque l9 que c'est quoi c'est
une blonde produits issus du mali en
riche en matériel donc oui ça se
retrouve sur des échelles et chez les
cocos d'il y a un peu cassé ce qu'ils
disent dans le c c'est une interview
c'est une question intéressante parce
que les arts causes en sont connues pour
ne pas avoir ce qu'il faut pour capter
les phéromones dans le néant tout cas
donc ce c'est une hypothèse c'est quand
même pas une petite hypothèse de faire
l'hypothèse des des phéromones
donc c'est vrai que c'est intéressant de
voir que les crocodiles ont
effectivement une glandes qui sécrètent
des phéromones même s'ils n'ont pas ce
qu'il faut pour les capter alors je sais
pas du coup par où ils les cas peut-être
par la langue ou peut-être pas je sais
pas je pense pas qu'ils parlent de
phéromones je parle je pense qu'il parle
juste de glandes
ce cri thouars ce serait juste l'odeur
quoi avec une odeur oui donc et donc ça
c'est pour l'article de jacques pin
mais il se trouve que tu est étudié avec
d'autres collègues à toi exactement le
même spécimens et vous avez publié alors
pas encore publié parce que c'était
sorti juste après frites mais tu vas
nous raconter l'histoire exacte de de
cet article en gros tu as publié toi
aussi une étude qui atteint des
conclusions légèrement différente et
notamment sur l'interprétation de la
forme du cloaque que vous que que toi et
tes collègues l'interpréter comme plus
crocodile yens on va dire c'est exact
c'est exact alors ça pourrait paraître
étonnant d'avoir deux articles sur le
même spécimens sur le cloaque de deux
équipes différents mais en fait il ya eu
un gros conflit d'intérêts donc c'est
une histoire assez longue que je peux
expliquer sans trop rentrer dans les
détails en fait je m'intéressais je
m'intéresse à la peau écailleuse des
dinosaures carnivores les théropodes
depuis depuis quelques mois j'ai
d'ailleurs une publication qui est en
quête in review pour le moment est donc
dans cette publication ce que je propose
c'est une matrice de données avec des
caractères tégument terre que j'ai connu
surtout chez les dinosaures carnivores
les théropodes mais également chez les
proches parents comme les
sauropodomorphes et divers
ornithischiens en encodant en fait si ta
cause russe qui a une
le spécimen à une peau écailleuse
extrêmement bien préservé mais j'ai
constaté justement que c'est pourri km
n'a jamais été publiée décrites dans les
détails et donc mérite une meilleure
description donc j'ai contacté en fait
jakob vinther et mayer pour savoir si je
pouvais proposer en fait une description
structure de la peau écailleuse de ce
spécimen ils sont ils demandé qui avait
pas de problème mais jakob vinther mme
parent fait que cette peau écailleuse a
été brièvement décrites dans les divers
papiers qui l'a publié sur ce spécimen
et ils en ont d'ailleurs fait une
reconstitution en trois dimensions à
partir d'une culture et juste après dans
une phrase qui suit celle de cette
sculpture en trois dimensions il me dit
on est en train également de
une reconstitution du cloaque avec mon
collègue bob nichols qui est donc à
paléo sculpteur s'est pas paléontologue
et une troisième personne
quand tu as cité le nom d'ailleurs tout
à l'heure quand j'ai dit non bref et
dont et que je ne connaissais pas
d'indiana les autres
voilà merci malheureusement je lis a
très brièvement très rapidement et dans
ma tête
il détend tout simplement en train de
faire une reconstitution du cloaque
à partir de cette sculpture et il est
pas en train de travailler là-dessus
grossière erreur puisque moi je dis à
mes collègues donc j'invite en fait le
spécialiste de la peau écailleuse des
dinosaures spécialiste du genre fil bell
qui est un australien absolument
adorable excellent vraiment le
spécialiste en la matière c'est ici
connaît très bien qui commence à
travailler sur scène politique et muse
de psittacosaurus j'invite également
michael pittmann a parlé entre eux que
c'est réputé au niveau des théropodes et
drôme les autorités c'est important de
rappeler que on parle énormément des
dinosaures à plumes et du coup on en
vient presque à oublier qu'ils avaient
surtout des écailles
ah oui c'est bien que tu ne sens pas
parce que c'est ça vient de rappeler
aussi que ils ont des équipes d'ailleurs
la plupart avec des écailles et absolue
dehors des terrains on peut même dire la
majorité des dinosaures avaient des
écailles puisque pour le moment on n'a
absolument aucune preuve de l'existence
alors ça c'est un autre chapitre à
j'étais là par contre c'est plus ma
tasse de thé et je vais publier
d'ailleurs quelque chose sur les
théropodes navia qui sont toujours
constitué maintenant en tout cas c'était
pas le cas auparavant qui sont toujours
constitué avec des plumes des proto plus
mais tout ça mais en tout cas chez les
théropodes bazzo comme par exemple
carnotaurus chez des dinosaures comme la
clause or chez les tyrannosauridés on a
que des preuves des cayes et on n'a pas
encore de preuve de
de filaments tégument terre mais ça
c'est encore autre chose mais c'est vrai
est par exemple tous les sauropodes
morts on a que des preuves des cayes
pour le moment la grande majorité des
ornithischiens comme les adrs or comme
les ceyrat obtient comme les terreaux
fort dont les en kilos d'or et les
stégosaures rien tout ça non que que des
cas ils ont une grande diversité des
cahiers alors c'est très intéressant et
je suis en train de travailler sur un
chapitre du livre de dinosaur et à
nantes en quelques clics dinosaur hunter
d'édition où on retrace un peu la
morphologie des tégument de ces
dinosaures et donc oui la majorité avait
quand même des écailles ci est le cas
donc je suis psittacose orge c'est le
cas de bon nombre de tonnes
donc oui ça c'est très bien de le
rappeler mais donc je reviens avec avec
cette histoire avec des copines teurs
donc malheureusement je l'interprète
très mal son email je me dis il
travaille en fait sur une reconstitution
du cloaque pour une une sculpture
sculpture d'ailleurs qui nous est que
qu'on a pu voir dans cette danse et
publications sur le les couleurs de
psittacose or une travail de sculpture
way et donc je disais que j'ai envie on
a invité également michael pittmann
puisque michael pittmann n'a pas
révolutionné le domaine des dinosaures à
plumes et tout ça et les cayes puisqu'en
fait il a proposé une nouvelle technique
à partir d'un laser ou ont fait il
utilise un laser pour révéler les
structures comme les écailles comme les
les plumes et tout ça
ils permettent vraiment de doré oui
vraiment de révéler certaines structures
qui ne pouvait pas être visible qu'il ne
pouvait pas être visible à l'oeil nu re
avec d'autres pays ayant en effet mike
hoffman a examiné ce dinosaure et les
photos qu'il a pu prendre de ce
dinosaure avec son collègue thomas sky
sont extraordinaires sont très très mais
vraiment très belle elle révèle très
bien les différentes et cas et qui sont
magnifiques
vraiment on voit que les différentes
morphologies des éclats c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que je voulais décrire ces
écarts
parce qu'elles sont très bien préservés
autant au niveau du cou qui au niveau
des épaules au niveau de la plante des
pieds ou les écailles sont différentes
et également au niveau de la queue et du
cloaque qui vraiment dans l'anatomie la
morphologie se révèle très bien avec ses
fautes logique évidemment d'invités
michael pittmann et là en fait mon
collègue fil bell passionné par la peau
écailleuse des dinosaures commence à
écrire la peau donc lésé cas est
différent et il commence également à
décrire des écailles au niveau du bloc
logiquement puisque le cloarec et quand
même défini par par dépit mais également
sur tout par des équipes et il s'emballe
et il constate en fait que le cloaque
évidemment n'a pas été décrit en détail
il a été juste brièvement décrit dans un
papier par terre et il se dit ils nous
contactent michael pittmann et moi même
en dix ans les gars franchement il
faudrait qu'on propose une publication
séparés pour le club parce que c'est un
on est des superbes de photos et ça nous
permet d'apporter des informations très
intéressantes quand on clôt rec qui
encore une fois les préserver que chez
ce spécimen là pour tous les dinosaures
non aviens et commence à décrire en qui
s'y connaît très bien il fait des
comparaisons avec les plots ait des
oiseaux des crocodiliens et des serpents
et tout ça et on a un papier de papier
donc un sur le cloaque et un sur les sur
les écailles d'obstacles aux eaux cde
papiers sont partagés sur dropbox avec
les nos autres collègues dont jakob
vinther jack comme buteur qu'on a
automatiquement invité dans ce papier
sur le club mais à mon avis je me dis
attendez les gars il ya quand même jack
fincher qui a fait une religion sur le
clos à qui j'ai l'impression qu'ils
entendent reconstitue le truc je vais
contacter vos droits pour être certain
du gers il travaille pas là dessus et
puis pour voir surtout s'il peut pas
nous donner des photos d'eux
de s'être contis reconstitution de de ce
spécimen
ce serait intéressant pour cette ce
papier et je le contacte et judith voilà
on est en train de travailler là-dessus
avec le fils béquilles et premier auteur
puisque c'est lui qui a tout écrit et
qui a passé le plus clair de son temps
sur ce projet là et nous répond très
rapidement et côté les gars non je suis
en train de travailler là dessus ça fait
plusieurs années que je travaille là
dessus avec deux collègues
s'il vous plaît ne travaillez pas là
dessus qu'on sente rigoureux sur les
écailles du reste de spécimens grosse
frustration puisque on se dit bon voilà
on s'est foutu on va pouvoir travailler
là dessus il faut abandonner c'est quand
même très dommage par rapport je me sens
mal d'ailleurs à fil bell a passé du
temps on s'était enthousiasmé quand
parce que vous savez quand même que ça
va être un papier qui allait publier
dans un truc important as et le cloaque
il eu la reproduction des dinosaures et
tout ça on savait qu'on allait pouvoir
publier ça l'a quand même dans une dans
un papier dans un journal importe
comment le cas arriver là arriver là en
faites vous tu pensais que tu avais
jakob vinther avec toi sur sur le truc
en fait alors que pour lui en fait il
travaillait il travaillait de son côté
depuis le début est en fait lui voulait
pas oui donc alors alors chaque homme
buteur nous dit très clairement écouter
une travailleurs travail est pas là
dessus parce que je suis en train de
travailler sur ce projet depuis même
plusieurs années
non vraiment je travaille il ya quand
même la frustration parce que vendre ça
c'est mon opinion personnelle je me dis
quand même que le gars aurait pu être
plus explicite dans son email très
sincèrement je lui ai envoyé un e-mail
en lui disant écoute tu parles
reconstitution du cloaque juste après la
le sculpture du clos de de spitak aux
russes aient mal interprété ça aurait
quand même pu être plus clair quant au
fait que tu travaillais sur le cloarec
dans une publication mais brit awards
donc nous dans mon email fil bell et moi
mr wrong se dit nombre d'accords très
bien battus travaille là dessus c'est ce
à quoi on pourrait continuer sauf que
mike pittman qui a partagé ses photos
qui révèle énormément de la morphologie
du bloc et des écailles avec k computer
pour une publication antérieure se dit
attendez les gars cydia coop vous
publiez sur le plan qui doit
automatiquement utiliser les photos puis
ce sont les meilleurs sur du genre donc
oui je vais quand même il m'a jamais
contacté m'a jamais demandé de faire
partie de son projet
j'ai quand même le contacter pour être
certain que si ils travaillent sur sur
vos photos baky qui nous contactent et
qui ne l'incluent parce que c'est quand
même et ils sont et ils sont venus en
allemagne ils ont développé une
technique et tout ça ils ont passé du
temps de l'argent et tout ça ce serait
frustrant quand même de voir leur photo
publiée dans non le pape qui est de jack
up sans qu'ils soient sans qu'il soit
invité donc là alors là c'est un truc
qui se passe de leur côté donc michael
pittmann contact jakob vinther lui
disant ben écoute franchement si tu
utilises mes photos bat nancy doit nous
inviter c'est la moindre des choses
sauf que giacobbe vinther dit non mais
attention on a publié ces photos
ensemble dans le supplément turine
formation d'ailleurs dans les appendices
de notre papier j'ai tout à fait le
droit de les utiliser et il a absolument
jacobine terre n'a absolument pas
l'intention donc d'inviter qui que ce
soit d'autre est dit que d'ailleurs
tchèque michael pittmann fait pression
sur lui alors tes devoirs
bref michael pittmann au final dit
écoutez les gars je sens très mal je
veux vraiment pas qu'il publie son
papier sur le cloaque avec mes photos je
trouve qu'il faudrait quand même qu'on
publie notre papier dans un prix prix
avec nos photos dans le but de préserver
la propriété intellectuelle quoi 2
deux des photos que j'ai prises avec mon
collègue temps masqué il arrive à
convaincre fil bell qui est le premier
auteur de publier ce prêt print je suis
franchement pas chaud parce qu'on a
quand même dit jakob vinther qu'on
travaillerait pas là dessus mais c'est
vrai on est quand même convaincu par
rapport au fait parce que je lui j'ai vu
des ihm et le jack up in turn 10 quand
même assez pas clairement mais il
sous-entend fait qu'il va utiliser quand
même les données de michael pittmann
juste parce que elles ont été publiées
dans un de papier qu'ils avaient
ensemble donc aussi bon ben alors
j'arrive
j'accepte de faire partie de ce projet
en 30 que dernier auteur c'est moi qui
initie le projet musique quasi rien fait
mais avec la seule et unique condition
que les bills à ce papier ne sera publié
avec mon nom dessus que si jakob vinther
fait partie du peuple
il me semble tout à fait logique travail
sur le plancton qui doivent faire partie
un compromis que mes collègues accepte
on publie ce truc en prie print je me
suis jamais senti aussi mal hein c'est
la première fois que ça m'est arrivé
parce que il ya quand même ce sentiment
qu'on fait quelque chose de éthiquement
parlant c'est un peu dodji c'est pas
super tout donc je le sens très mal
et voilà le jour où le plus le print et
dépublié email de tout comme vinther qui
est très très très dur qui nous dit
qu'on l'a trahi qui ne lui avais dit
qu'on n'avait pas travaillé là dessus et
bing on a ce truc là
et moi je dit écoute je suis d'accord je
comprends ta réaction mes contacts fil
bell
parce que c'est lui le premier auteur et
c'est lui qui a pris vendrait contacte
donc voilà à filmer sur le terrain en ce
moment là et puis il reprend contact
avec comme leader en lui disant voilà
bah écoute on comprend pas pourquoi t'as
pas inclus michael pittmann alors qu'ils
projetaient d'apporter des informations
hyper intéressant par rapport à la
morphologie du cloaque avec ses photos
moi même donc fil bell lui même apporté
des informations hyper intéressante et
donc on aurait pu être inclus mais bref
jacobine thorn n'a pas souhaité bon bref
tout ça pour dire que jacob littéraire
très énervé qu'on a un gros conflit
d'intérêts qu'ils le souhaitent avoir
aucun contact avec nous donc voilà deux
publications séparer une qui a été
publié donc cette de jakob vinther qui
ne cite absolument pas la nôtre bah oui
c'est logique puisque la nôtre elle
l'est par elle n'a pas été pyrobio et et
c'est un prêt print et puis surtout le
mec est hyper énervé par rapport à nous
donc il a décidé de l'ignorer
ce qui est respectable virtu doit
normalement pas t'es pas obligé
normalement de citer un père un premier
qui n'a pas été revu mais c'est quand
même accepté même si certaines personnes
se sont étonnés non c'est pas illogique
nous en tout cas desquels dans quelle
position se trouve pour le moment un
fils bel et moi même on préfère d'être
vivement
à voir cette partie sur le cloaque
inclus dans ce papier sur le reste de dt
gumende psittacose or on se tait pas
quelle est la position de michael
pittmann pour maman en tout cas c'est
fil bell qui a écrit tout le papier non
puisque lui ne souhaiterait pas avoir un
papier c'est pareil je crois que l'une
des fortes chances que ça n'arrive pas
dans le futur
voilà ça c'est l'explication très longue
je m'en excuse
par rapport à ça ce qui est très
important à dire c'est que manifestement
on a une interprétation différente de la
morphologie du club grec
vinther voit en fait deux lèvres
antérieures qui se joignent forme avait
donc ces deux lèvres qui latéral qui
seront pimentés et ben nous c'est de
lèvres on y vont en fait deux parties
détaché du plô ac donc le corps avec
pour interprètes tout à fait comme une
une une fente longitudinale donc d'avant
en arrière comme chez les crocodiliens
pas de l'intérêt qu'ils nous le cloaque
est donc préservée en deux parties selon
nous on apporte plus d'informations par
rapport à lanquetot génie donc c'est à
dire au fait que le l'animal est
certainement un subadulte donc c'est un
animal qui a certainement atteint une
certaine maturité sexuelle comme vinther
n'est pas capable de d'avoir des
informations par rapport au sexe de
l'animal
on ne peut pas dire s'il s'agit d'un
mâle et d'une femelle pour les mêmes
raisons puisque des organes copulatoire
sont internes et donc bien on fait une
description un peu plus détaillée des
écailles qui entoure le club et c'est à
peu près tout très sincèrement notre
publication
et ce différentiel assez bien de celle
dewinter haut niveau en fait tout
simplement du roll off actifs ont pas on
dit on ne parle pas de ça on constate en
effet que le cloarec et foncé mais on ne
se prononce pas par rapport à la
fonction de signalement nous on dit en
tout cas que le club
avec est plus proche de celui des
crocodiliens puisque c'est une fente
longitudinale alors que vinther ne se
prononce pas là dessus a dit que n'est
pas capable de te savoir la morphologie
de l'ouverture du cloaque
et voilà et je suppose que nous allons
donc discuter de la morphologie diplômes
proposés par vinther d'un papier sur sur
la peau écailleuse de psittacose or
d'accord mais quand même donc oui comme
tu précises de votre article est quand
même plus long et à plus de détails et
les photos sont effectivement très très
détaillé et très elles sont très très
belle quoi je laissais c'est vrai que
l'on voit du coup le rôle qu'a joué le
conte jouer les fameuses photos mais
c'est avec du coup si l'article n'est
pas publié au final il ya enfin je sais
pas est ce que vous avez l'intention de
finalement le publier cet article ou
est-ce qu'il va rester à l'état de près
print ou est-ce que vous allez le
rétracter ou c'est ce que je disais un
jeu justement de long par les fils belle
et moi même on n'est pas chaud pour
publié ce papier séparément donc pour
nous qu'il reste à l'état de près fines
n'est pas un problème
ce qu'on a l'intention donc c'est
d'inclure les deux parties sur le
cloaque et la morphologie dit flo et
dans le papier le reste délicat et de
psychose or ce serait en citant jacob
dit man of jakob vinther rue et en
citant jakob vinther évidemment on va
pour un coût permettre de l'ignorer
puisque non il par l'absurde et dans
l'est dans la discussion est toujours
une part toute discussion résultats
discussions dans la partie diffusion on
va parler de discuter de cette
morphologie proposé par vinther puisque
manifestement on a une interprétée donc
c'est surtout ouais c'est surtout après
print qui est sorti pour sauver la
propriété intellectuelle c'est pour
envoyer un message à vinther quoi que
c'était unique si c'est pas très bien
ouais c'est pas très déontologique de sa
part d'utiliser des contenus qu'il n'a
pas créé
même pour un article sans contacter la
personne en tout cas c'est une situation
dans laquelle je souhaiterais vraiment
ne pas me retrouver donc j'ai appris
j'ai appris certaines le font voilà les
conflits d'intérêts ça ça prend souvent
à la dure mais bon bref voilà aller
continuons avec les états et donc
justement on parlait de descriptions de
grande précision des écailles et tu
parlais que tu que tu étudier ces
écailles chez les ch et des dinosaures
théropodes est justement tu as sorti
donc deux articles sur un spécimen très
très bien préservés de jus ramène à tort
et une fois de plus sur la queue de cet
animal ça va encore être un des
histoires de cul tu as retrouvé des tu
as retrouvé avec la même équipe c'est à
dire toi fils belle une grande ville
belle et moi uniquement filmer les toits
voit bien que vous avez vous avez
retrouvé donc des écailles différents
types des cas et donc c'est à dire que
le vent on a tendance à un peu simplifié
l'histoire entre justement écailler plus
mme may de même qu'il y à différents
types de plume il y à différents types
des cayes donc et tout ça ça se voit
très bien chez jura-bienne attendant
qu'est ce que tu peux nous décrire ce
qui se passe j'ai joué venator bien sûr
je vais débuter
d'abord par le côté un peu historique
parce que tours ça intéressant sans
rentrer trop haut il faut dans les
détails
voilà moi je m'intéresse en fait surtout
à l'évolution des dents et des os
porteurs de dents chez les dinosaures
carnivores donc ça m'a amené à visiter
un très grand nombre d'institutions de
collection et donc je vois là j'ai eu
l'opportunité de d'aller en allemagne de
visiter le superbe musée qui est cite
d'ailleurs dans un château donc j'invite
vraiment les thés auditeurs à se rendre
au musée des stats qui qui a plusieurs
celui-ci mais extraordinaire dont les
deux plus importants en tout cas pour
moi passer l'archaeopteryx ils ont un
spécimen d'archaeopteryx très bien
préservé des 6000 mégawatts et je ramène
à tort jura venator qui est un spécimen
extraordinaire parce que c'est pas
contre soglo nette idée quasi-complet
préserver dans c'est quelqu'un à miner
r1 ceux qui ont donc
ni tous les to les archéoptéryx et ainsi
que le type de console nature et jura
venator est quasi complet et surtout est
très très bien préservé puisque et bien
il est préservé
ce spécimen préserve des écailles
toi-même et également des protoplumes
super atteint donc on verra quand
j'examine ce spécimen jeu j'ai acheté un
microscope portable très très utile qui
me permet de prendre des photos surtout
détendez denticules et comme je savais
qu'il avait des écailles avec ça
m'intéressait assez bien les la peau des
dinosaures j'ai décidé de prendre des
photos de ses écailles non seulement
avec mon appareil photo mais également
avec microscope électronique et j'ai
quand même dans cette idée de développer
un projet sur la peau écailleuse des
terreaux plus que je constate
franchement qui a pas grand chose qui a
été publié dessus très très peu de
choses et 1 et j'invite très
naturellement fils belle affaire parce
qu'il partie de ce projet puisque il est
le spécialiste de la politique des
dinosaures depuis énormément sur les son
rapport sur les tendances sur les abords
et je partage évidemment toutes les
photos que j'ai pu prendre des écailles
que j'ai examiné dans différents musées
dont les équipes de la marine actor et
un jour je reçois un email en me disant
écoute j'ai pu voir les photos que tu as
pu prendre deux juras vie nateur des
écarts de yoann a tort franchement je
suis impressionné parce que déjà je
constate qu'il ya 3 et khâgne trois
types des cas édifiant il puis un type
des cayes qui semble avoir des disques
comme ça et manifestement j'ai
l'impression que ça me rapporte des
informations très intéressantes par
rapport à ces écailles alors super super
intéressant je regarde les photos que
j'ai pu prendre mais en effet je
constate en effet c'est qui qui s est
dit ce que je n'avais absolument pas vu
auparavant donc scellé l'oeil de
l'expert qui m'a montré quelque chose
que je n'avais pas vu et voilà de fil en
aiguille et qu'on a travaillé là-dessus
lui en tant que premier auteur puisque
c'est spécial ans qui écrit très bien et
où moi en tant que deuxième moteur mais
j'ai quand même fait toutes les figures
it ou est ce qu'on a pu le constater
chez lui ramène à tort
mais pas été publié auparavant parce
qu'il ya pas mal de publication sur jura
venator sur la peau d'or à l'ena thor
dont une qui a été publié en 2000
varades qui dit justement que les
écailles toujours année à tort ne sont
pas des cas ce sont des as 10 po servent
c'est à dire des restes de grèce et que
c'est pour ça qu'on en retrouve
d'ailleurs qu'au niveau de la queue
parce qu'il faut le savoir les écailles
ce ne se retrouve qu'au niveau de la
queue on n'a pas d'autres restent des
cayes mais nous on dit que maintenant
dans ce papier en dînant et les gars
c'est pas du tout de la vie post et pas
des restes de grèce c'est vraiment des
écailles pour la simple et bonne raison
que on a vraiment des déséquilibres et
pète dans la morphologie et elle se
répète parfaitement avec une sorte
d'arbre ication qui parfaite
et puis on a surtout ses écailles
hexagonal qui portent des disques
surmonté d'un anneau et qui se retrouve
vraiment chez toutes les écoles du même
type dans la même partie de de la queue
de l'animal
donc on est tout à fait convaincu qu'il
s'agit des cakes ça ne peut pas être
autre chose et donc dans un premier
papier qu'on a publié également dans
current biology donc en tant que
correspondante comme le cloaque dewinter
ce qu'on a pu dire c'est que c'est
qu'être hexagonal qu'on retrouve sur la
partie ventrale donc la partie basse de
la queue de journée à tort ces écailles
hexagonal tout petit a qui font quelques
millimètres seulement de diamètre
donc qui montre une sorte de disque
surmonté d'un anneau qui est situé
postérieurement et ça c'est intéressant
aussi au niveau de l'accueil eh bien on
les interprète comme des récepteurs de
pression en forme de dôme des récepteurs
que l'on retrouve également chez les
écailles des crocodiliens pas tous les
quotidiens surtout les crocodiles les
crocodiles en sont pourvus absolument
sur la totalité du corps en tout cas une
grande partie du corps en revanche les
alligators très intéressant non que haut
niveau
de la tête du crâne et si je ne me
trompe du musée met donc on retrouve ce
genre des cayes
avec ce petit disque qui est également
localisé dans la partie postérieure de
les cayes chez les crocodiles ya et ce
sont donc des écailles qui ont un rôle
tactique c'est à dire qu'ils sont
capables de détecter des mouvements dans
l'eau un chez les quotidiens et donc
qu'est ce qu'on en dit eh bah voilà
qu'on savait très bien quand même que je
lui ramène à tort et à un animal
terrestre on n'imagine pas qu'il était
aquatique n'ont aucune adaptation à ce
mode de vie aquatique
mais par contre c'est un animal dont qui
vit en fait sur cet archipel de sol et
nobel a donc l'allemagne
il y à 155 millions et un dans le jura
stick supérieur en allemagne c'est une
zone qui est tropical avec des toutes
petites îles d or asie sur des choses
comme ça c'est un peu le la polynésie
française du jurassique en allemagne et
bien ceux des animaux qui devait vivre
évidemment sur les parties côtière de
ces îles à qui on qu'il devait donc
avoir un accès facile à la mer qui
pouvaient s'y nourrir on imagine donc
que ces écailles tactile devait avoir un
rôle de de détection de mouvements
lorsque l'animal se plonger une partie
du corps dans la mer est donc
complètement sait très bien que les
dinosaures théropodes avait une queue
quasi horizontal qui ne reposait pas sur
la terre donc on en déduit que cette
queue n'est pas utilisé comme les
parisans de les serpents les il semble
que les certains les arts ont également
ses écailles tactile mais eux par contre
leur corps repose sur le sol ce qui
n'est pas le cas avec lui ramène à tort
donc nous on pense vraiment que c'est un
animal qui devait très certainement
détecter des proies quoi tic des
poissons dans les eaux côtières de cette
petite
de cet archipel et qu'il devait se
nourrir donc de poissons ce qui n'est
pas illogique non plus puisque des
proches parents de jura bienne à tort je
revienne à tort est interprété comme un
conte cionet idée on ad'autres contre ce
que l'attitude du moins à un ski bionics
un juvénile qui a été trouvé en italique
extrêmement bien préservé avec des
restes de poissons dans son que dans ses
intestins
donc on sait très bien qu'il ya des
proches parents de jura venator qui se
nourrissait de poisson donc il n'est pas
illogique de penser que c'est un animal
qui devait être également au moins
partiellement piscivores il le vit donc
dans un environnement plutôt côtier il a
uni la des écailles sensible au niveau
de l'accueil notre seul et unique
interprétation logique c'est qu'il
devait utiliser c'est que pour détecter
ses proies
cette campagne des couilles il devait
avoir le corps entier recouvert de ses
écailles tu penses
non alors ça on n'en sait rien non c'est
pas non on sait en tout cas au niveau de
la queue puisque seuls les et qu'elles
sont préservés au niveau de la queue on
retrouve ces 10 cas uniquement de la
partie basse de la que ce qui est
logique aussi et encore une fois à c'est
plutôt la partie basse de la queue c'est
ce qu'on retrouve aussi chez les cocos
dire en tout cas on sait très bien que
la partie basse de de l'animal est
recouvert de ses écailles sensible pour
détecter des proies
c'est ce qu'on retrouve chez jura n'a
tort puisque les as et l'autre papier on
sait que les écailles du de la partie
supérieure de la queue sont différents
noms passés c'est ces récepteurs de
pression de forme de dôme puis sur ses
écailles au dessus de la creuse sont
triangulaire en forme de
de lance de poèmes de lens et elles sont
imbriqués et non pas ces récepteurs de
pression et puis alors tant que ça c'est
dans cet autre papier on constate donc
le réalisateur montre ont seulement des
[Musique]
excuses moi des sortes de poils des
pigments filamentaire des filaments sur
le haut du corps mais également trois
types des cayes donc la première située
sur le haut du coeur triangulaire et un
briquet deuxième celle du collège est
décrite donc assez en détails qui sont
hexagonal et qui sont surmontés de ce
disque avec des anneaux et puis la
troisième
ce sont des écueils que l'on retrouve au
niveau du ventre des serpents qui sont
des cas est assez grande
allongé et perpendiculaires à la queue à
laax de la queue très intéressant aussi
première premier type des cayes à être
répertoriés chez un dinosaure
on a pu constater également se passe
dans ce deuxième papier que les biens il
y avait un autre dinosaure carnivore qui
en étaient pourvus concavenator à 4,40
hantise carcharodontosaures idée pardon
basale qui montre également des segments
comme ça au niveau de la partie
intérieure de la queue et qui donc
manifestement été pourvus de ce même
type dégâts donc ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que l'heure et bien il semblerait
que certains théropodes on sait pas si
tous les théropodes en étaient pourvus
mais en tout cas il semblerait que
autant les confessions et idées que les
halles aux ordres ou ikea où les
éleveurs l'idée dans les halles aux
autorités par an et est pourvu de ce
type des cayes allongé qu'on appelle des
écaillers discuter ventre terme d'accord
c'est marrant parce que je crois qu'on a
donc on n'a pas d'empreintes de peau de
10 m dont par contre on a des des ics no
daisy cnit quoi des empreintes de pas
fils de dix mètres aux dons et en
pologne si je ne m'abuse ayant il ya une
de ses pistes ou en fait l'animal s'est
relâché owen lâcher ses jambes s'est
posé sur le sol et du coup on voit
l'empreinte du ventre et on voit aussi
ses espèces des cayes allongé comme ça
aussi sur le ventre de 2 10 m dont pour
à l'interrogation pas ce que dit métro
dont en pologne je crois pas qu on en a
retrouvé deux squelettes mais être
appliquée aux ordres voilà c'est
attribué en tout cas applique aux ordres
semblables à 10 mais trop dans quoi et
c'est hyper intéressant c'est très
intéressant
alors ce qu'on a proposé c'est un rôle
plutôt prospectifs
un des écailles acea s'est allongée donc
on les retrouve chez les ch et les
serpents mais vraiment ils rampent sur
le sol est ce que ce sont des écailles
un peu plus résistantes aux leurres
résistantes aux parasites également 10
mars est rien je peux vous dire en fait
et ça c'est un scoop qu'on retrouve
également ce type dès qu'ils aillent
chez un autre dinosaure théropode très
connu de la formation morrison je ne
dirai pas plus très fréquents dans
d'autres parties du corps alors c'est
une information qui m'a été partagé il
ya quoi il ya une semaine donc c'est un
truc les un spécimen très bien préservés
voilà un dinosaure carnivore le plus
fréquent de la mauricienne la forme une
formation morrison et on l'a retrouvé
dans d'autres parties du corps non pas
chez au niveau de la queue mais un peu
plus haut dans quoi donc voilà ça c'est
un scoop donc je vais pas en parler plus
que ça évidemment j'ai été inclus dans
ce programme très excitant mais oui donc
ça veut dire que c'est un type des cas
qui devaient se retrouver chez au moins
au moins d'autres dinosaures carnivores
et alors que parler de l'empreinte de de
bon comme ça j'étais un pays cause
lorsque le bas du ventre
et bien il semblerait quand même la même
chose si un ornithischiens basale en
tout cas ça a été interprété comme ça au
niveau de la queue
un aussi et donc c'est une empreinte de
queue qui a été retrouvé dans le
jurassique inférieur des états unis et
donc voilà ça ne nous dit quand même que
la partie inférieure du corps de pas mal
de dinosaures devait être recouverts de
ce type des cayes allongée donc voilà
donc c'est très intéressant ces titres
je regarde donc j'étais article sous les
yeux et enfin ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
beaucoup impressionné c'est la qualité
de la représentation de jura venator le
artwork de jake bartz ouais est ce que
tu peux commenter un petit peu comment
vous avez dirigé la reconstitution de du
jura venator avec lui avec un immense
plaisir donc autant films et de moi même
on est très intéressé de fournir de
proposer une reconstitution de ce
dinosaure la manière la plus précise
possible et donc puisqu'on savait quand
même que faut déjà savoir 9 est
important de le signaler c'est que nous
on a on a ici en étant tenir
communicationnel eux le journal nikkei
communication avec les deux les deux
articles associés c'est à dire que l'on
disait non seulement qu'on avait ce type
ces écailles sensible et également la
diversité de trucs ça a été refusé
ce qui nous a permis d'ailleurs de
publier deux articles dont un qui a
quand même qui est assez prestigieux
dans un journal à ce prestigieux l'autre
dans une revue quand même très bonne
aussi paléontologie donc on est très
content avec ce résultat là et je dis ça
par cuba pourquoi parce que dans ce
premier article qu'on a souvenir nature
communications vous était quand même
voilà fournir cette reconstitution une
belle reconstitution d'ailleurs à tort
puisque en fournissant des informations
quant aux écailles extérieur donc c'est
quand même très intéressant donc on me
cherchait des pas les artistes sur
internet et on a trouvé d'accord bars
qui participe en fait un jeu
important qui s'appelle comment je me
rappelais plus c'est pas grave mais qui
a un jeu virtuel avec des
reconstitutions très très précise de
dinosaures on la constate on l'a
contacté on lui a dit voilà on
souhaitait ans souhaiterait avoir une
reconstitution de julian acteurs précise
la plus juste possible avec les
informations qu'ont fourni dans le
papier est tout à fait et il est très
content et il commença à nous proposer
des différentes sculptures c'est
vraiment un processus qui a pris plus
d'un mois il ya vraiment des différentes
étapes et moi je sais quelque chose que
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup faire donc ou
en allant se prononcent non seulement
sur les écailles mais également sur la
morphologie du crâne la posture la
morphologie des membres antérieurs la
queue et tout ça et nous a fait une
reconstitution extraordinaire on est
très content elle a été leakée des
centaines de fois sur twitter donc ce
gala a eu énormément de succès par
rapport à ça il ya aussi la constitution
des légumes en élémentaire qui se
retrouvent sur sur le haut du corps on
est très très content pour savoir par
exemple au niveau de la couleur
ce qu'il faut se prononcer aussi sur la
couleur on connaît absolument pas la
couleur eu de ce dinosaure là on connaît
par exemple la couleur d'un proche
parent qui est sinosauropteryx consoler
à l'idée qu'il y avait donc des stripes
ce sont des bandes au niveau de la queue
on voulait pas faire pareil avec ce
dinosaure la hante
en revanche on savait que c'était un
duvet ni l'injure ordinateurs étaient
décrits en tant que juré nil donc on
voulait quand même montré que c'était un
dinosaure qui devait avoir des couleurs
qui est qui se rapproche plus de celle
des juvéniles de des oiseaux on utilise
quand même fortement les zozos puisque
ce sont des théropodes est donc là voilà
on a reconstitué un ordinateur avec des
couleurs de juvéniles de ce que sont les
oies ou de canard ou deux
pour je ne me rappelle pas je crois ce
sont des oies avec ces partis font c est
clair qu'ils se retrouvent sur l'animal
pour ça très beau et puis il a fait il
l'a fait ça de manière très juste avec
les équipes qui sont quand même visible
et puis seulement quelques filaments
réglementaire qui se retrouvent sur le
corps puisque d'après nous franchement
c'est finalement ne se retrouvent que le
seulement sur le haut du corps
chose qui n'est n'a pas été proposée par
d'autres ni à un autre auteur d'autres
auteurs qui disent que c'est finalement
devait découvrir comme une autre une
grande grande partie du corps mais on a
une interprétation de temps donc voilà
il nous a proposé cette reconstitution
qu'on trouve très juste on est très
content et grâce à ça voilà notre papier
s'est retrouvé dans le national
geographic et c'est chouette quoi c'est
vraiment super comme quoi franchement
c'est ça qui me gêne vraiment je suis
passionnée par mon travail et j'ai pris
des photos avec mon mon microscope
électronique des des écailles de
dinosaures et c'est assez retrouvez donc
dans d'autres publications et d'un
article dans le national geographic
vraiment génial qu'on sait c'est
chouette de voir les résultats de sept
de ces deux projets et voilà je suis
très content de colabor réussi avec fil
bell qui est absolument géniale qui
travaille très bien qui est comme toi
qui es vraiment effectif très agréable
et on a donc pas mal d'autres papiers je
peux déjà d'ores et déjà vous dire qu'on
va avoir un papier sur les écailles de
carnotaurus qui n'ont jamais été la peau
écailleuse de carnotaurus et appelé les
autorités qui n'a jamais été donc un
billet de manière détaillée
ok bon bah super merci beaucoup
christophe de nous avoir accordé de ton
temps c'était super sympa et puis très
très clair et très instructif on a à la
fois donc la science qui progresse mais
aussi un petit peu les bagues en des
backstage de la science et de ce qui se
passe derrière les aider les communiqués
de presse est ce que je souhaitais faire
aussi un donc l'avis de paléontologues
n'est pas toujours facile donc pour pas
qu'on ne faut pas savoir que en écoutant
sur le terrain alors y ait parfois
malheureusement il ya des conflits avec
des collègues mais et puis je vous ai
expliqué aussi comment on arrive avec
des professions collaboration avec des
pailles aux artistes pour sa part être
aussi intéressant à cette tactique de
l'être humain est un singe politique
mais c'est bien là tu nous as tu nous a
montré plein d'aspects de du travail du
paléontologue
donc c'est vraiment super intéressant
donc merci encore
nous avons accordé de ton temps j'espère
qu'on se reverra très bientôt pour une
prochaine publication super
intéressantes comme ça et puis je dis à
tout le monde à très bientôt sur notre
chaîne salut
[Musique]